[Applaudissements]
on va faire une minute de silence pour
mon physique
le mec se kiffe en fait
[Rires]
ça va être ça va être long
voilà pourquoi vous ferez jamais
d'audience
vous ne comprenez rien aux aphnis voilà
pourquoi 100000 100.000 100000 voilà
300000 à 3 merci à tous c'est bon
[Applaudissements]
je suis content ah je suis content
je suis content
je suis content je suis content je suis
content franchement je suis content
en fait aujourd'hui je lui dis la vérité
la chaîne n'a pas voulu me payer
c'est rare enfin
j'avais pas vu mon frère on fait une
minute de silence pourquoi pas tu te
mets là on fait une nuit de deux
j'adore Katie elle veut faire la même
chose pour vous incroyable ça vous plaît
mais c'est quoi cette beuh bon c'est
cassis qui a fait ça arrête avec Cathy
c'est toi que je vois elle a fait
c'est quoi cette bonbon
c'est parti envoyer une envoyer une
musique là on va y aller
[Applaudissements]
sur la tête ou ma mère on était chez
Balmain vous voulez qu'on soit chez
balle pied
S
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
cette tenue tu as mis deux fois
[Rires]
à l'école
le matin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça va c'est bien
faut jamais sourire maintenant
[Rires]
à consommer avec modération ah les gars
c'est bon j'ai fait mon petit tour les
gens ont pu voir ma personne les gens
sont avec nous voilà c'est bon et voilà
par contre ça là tu en as plusieurs ou
c'est toujours la même
c'est toujours la même je vais laver
sur ma vie c'est la messe la plus lavée
de France c'est pas la laver frère c'est
un truc de ouf c'est un dis-moi
[Rires]
on t'embrasse on l'adore et là il se dit
frère bam ça m'est tombé dessus l'amour
BIM tac là il est en ribéchamel il se
voit il est comme un ouf franchement il
t'a pas contacté le restaurant non plus
t'as pas appelé non personne t'a appelé
même la police
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
dans la presse
[Rires]
est-ce que vous constatez
mon conseil j'en ai envoyé des gens dans
le mur est-ce que vous me conseillez de
réserver pour le restaurant Le Jour de
le soir de mon anniversaire comme
anniversaire le 2 novembre le 2 novembre
disait que je ferai peut-être un peu de
peine mais alors on me dit que de faire
la peine aux gens c'est pas bon pour
faire de la peine parce que si je suis
toute seule à table
qui font de la peine
avec un beau mec ça va pas non plus
elle va encore plus super de la peinture
c'est pas ça c'est pas sa client
èle toi tu viens à la maison avec Kelly
je regarde que toi
ça rigole c'est vrai la meilleure idée
regarde que toi pour t'inviter à partir
[Applaudissements]
es à mon avis il faut qu'elle aille avec
moi
moi je pense qu'il faut qu'elle aille à
la fermeture du restaurant à 1h30 du
matin pour faire
le
ménagement
ils sortent de trois tranquille au
suboku
c'est bon les gars
donc s'il vous plaît non ta gueule
stratégie elle est très simple ton
anniversaire c'est le 2 novembre je vais
venir avec toi là-bas
on va y aller on va manger tous les deux
il sait que vous avez pas de zizi donc
il est tranquille
c'est ça ton problème non
on va prendre
une entrée un plat au moment du dessert
je vais de gauche
ça j'aime bien et voilà je vais être
galoche d'accord je vais arriver comme
acheter galoche là il va arriver enfin
ouais c'est ma meuf non mais là c'est la
joie
je l'avais vu en premier que c'était
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
quand tu viens trop souvent tu déclines
donc tu sois sortir un peu va faire un
tour va te recoiffer derrière parce
qu'on dirait que tu es je me suis coiffé
tout seul
faire des économies non mais fais faire
les économies à personne allez va te
coiffer trouver quelqu'un voilà
n'importe quoi
[Rires]
pour sortir
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
incroyable
mais là la soirée de rêve c'est sûr
c'est bon tu vas y aller avec quelqu'un
quoi c'est loin alors le 2 novembre
tout de suite
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]